[Music]
ladies and gentlemen my next guest is a
very talented comedian who is making her
late night television debut with us here
tonight and can be seen at the moon
tower comedy and oddity festival in
austin texas please welcome you're very
funny aaron foley
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello
super excited to be here tonight i've
got some good news out of the gates i'm
in a new relationship which is super fun
yeah
i know it's exciting she's amazing she's
absolutely fantastic uh i know she
meaning i'm gay take a second and we're
back and we're back
yeah no fresh balls for me and uh
it's definitely a story of like
opposites of track because she owns a
beauty school in san francisco and i own
a hairbrush from 1992.
yeah it's uh i tell you that whole like
you know hair and beauty world is so
overwhelming to me like i went to cvs
just to get some hair conditioner seems
simple enough no not at all there's like
50 different types of hair conditioner
and the labels are getting so rude it's
like is your hair dry is it damaged is
it exhausted is it mangled is it
desperate for moisture
does your hair look like a tumbleweed
is it burnt cracked poison macabre are
you dead inside
i just want to feel pretty
yeah my world is sports i'm like a crazy
insane sports fan because sometimes
stereotypes are true
i uh
i own a softball glove nobody panic and
uh
i love baseball i love baseball just
started super exciting and uh here's the
thing i think we all can agree on
baseball the salaries outrageous
absolutely outrageous paul's just signed
a 240 million dollar contract in the
offseason 240 million dollars let's
break this down uh because we're here uh
a good uh batting average in baseball is
300 meaning you get to the plate 10
times you hit the ball three times
that's a 30
success rate and they're getting
hundreds of millions of dollars think
about it any other job in america if you
have a 30
success rate uh you're fired yeah
because you're horrible at your job
right
i mean it's ridiculous
that's like if you're like a waiter and
you go over the table and you're like
here's your chicken parm and rib eye
steak we ordered the salmon enjoy
or you're like a surgeon in the
emergency room best day ever 10 people
got wheeled in i saved four hall of fame
numbers
yeah love the sports i also like to read
because i'm literate which is pretty
awesome um i was at a bookstore recently
there's i think there's four left and uh
i tell you when you're at the bookstore
there's a there's like a lot of
depressing books out there books on wars
and plagues and poverty but then i
discovered the most depressing book of
all time it's actually in the cooking
section it's called vegan cooking for
one
that's pretty bad
that's pretty much
no meat no fish no dairy no fred screw
it throw in the towel
on the back of the buckets if you love
vegan cooking for one you'll love the
bell jar by sylvia plath
it's pretty nerdy pretty nerdy
a lot of uh not a lot of good news
anywhere the economy oh boy
that's in the tanker uh the other day i
heard consumer confidence is at its
lowest point in 28 years and i was like
oh man
i don't even know what that means it
just sounds horrible
i just pictured this woman leaving wall
walk leaving walmart hysterically crying
to be like
i don't know what happened
i used to love to shop
i'm a shopper now i don't have any
confidence
i can't even find my purse
i'm so tired
i'm just so tired
ah and she dies
not a lot of good news divorce rates uh
just skyrocketing everyone always tries
to explain divorce by comparing it to
other generations which uh i don't think
you can do you know you hear this a lot
like well in the olden days you know
people just stayed together and worked
it out no
in the olden days people died younger
actually that's what happened
they didn't have better communication
skills they had infectious diseases
it's like you're married at 18 you're
dead at 35 boom perfect marriage
you're the love of my life i have the
plague that we had a good run
that's it for me thank you guys so much
thank you very much
[Applause]